jetzt haben wir richtig gute nachrichten
der bund darf den ländern doch 5
milliarden für die digitale aufrüstung
unserer schulen schenken hat der
bundestag gestern auf den weg gebracht
den sogenannten digital packt angeblich
so hört man ohne allzu viel hilfe von
der zuständigen bildungsministerin anja
karliczek wir machen heute einfach mal
den carlitscheck check24 meine damen und
herren ja fast ein jahr im amt und das
zwischenzeugnis nach diesem
schnupperpraktikum fällt durchwachsen
aus
die quereinsteigerin aus ibbenbüren hat
wenn man wirklich alles zusammenzählt
einen gesetzentwurf ins kabinett
gebracht zum thema waffe und das ist
schade
frau carlitscheck verfügt nämlich über
den viertgrößten etat aller minister ist
aber offenbar immer noch so ein bisschen
in der orientierungsphase
da ich in diesem bereich sommer wenig
kenntnisse von innen habe kann ich
vielleicht die richtigen fragen stellen
fragen die ein anderer nicht mehr fragen
würde werde so lange fragen fragen und
fragen und fragen fragen fragen fragen
fragen und fragen sich ein gutes gefühl
habe wie der hase da so läuft ja du
schön schön
[Musik]
noch besser als gefühle wäre wissen denn
deswegen hat die wissenschaftsministerin
und nicht gefühlt ministerin
überragend ist allerdings ihre
fettnäpfchen bilanz nach nur einem jahr
wir erinnern uns man kriegt gar nicht
mehr alles zusammen 5g braucht man nicht
an jeder milchkanne zitat ende
sie fragt können homosexuelle überhaupt
kinder großziehen und ihr neuester klopp
hat zum thema bafög und hohe mieten
zitat man muss ja nicht in die teuersten
städte geht
ach ja ach ja haben sie gesagt und der
deutsche lehrerverband meckert dass sie
noch nicht einmal vorbei gekommen ist in
einem jahr
was machst du denn stattdessen ich habe
intensiv meine zeit wirklich im letzten
jahr da dem gewidmet einen guten
überblick zu bekommen also was für ein
geiler satz oder pokal ich habe mir
extra nen t shirt drucken lassen ehrlich
wer will auch für sie wenn der chef sie
fragt was genau arbeiten sie eigentlich
in meiner firma dann fragen sie ich habe
intensiv meine zeit wirklich im letzten
jahr neben gewidmeten guten überblick zu
bekommen
[Applaus]
wenn man immer euch jetzt
heute übrigens jeder in unserem team
haben dieses t shirt meine damen und
herren ja sogar der koalitionspartner
spd verliert langsam die geduld mit anja
karliczek zögern sie bitte nicht uns
ihre gesetzentwürfe zuzuleiten wir haben
sehr viele mittel also in die hufe ja
wobei eins will carlitscheck wohl
tatsächlich auf den weg bringen und zwar
die umbenennung von handwerker
abschlüssen in berufs bachelor viel
besser oder
dann heißt es endlich gas wasser scheiße
welt schlacht statt installateur ja wer
weiß vielleicht sehen wir ungerecht
vielleicht sollte man die frau auch
nicht unterschätzen
wer weiß wo ihr weg noch hinführt weißt
du was ich hole mir immer gerade eine
schöne tasse tee manche kollegen
scherzen als nächstes würde sie
vermutlich kanzlerin werden leute mit
sowas scherz man nicht wirklich jetzt
übrigens tatsächlich meine brille knast
tatsächlich hätte unsere bildungs und
forschungsministerin sehr viel zu tun
ich sage nur künstliche intelligenz
dahin deutschland brutal hinterher und
vergleich zu china oder den amerikanern
das ist peinlich
andererseits wir sind aber auch nicht in
den usa wir gehen einen anderen einen
eigenen weg wir lassen uns von unserem
christlichen menschenbild leiten jeder
technologische fortschritt hat sich
dahinter ein zu sein sagt die für
forschung und wissenschaft zuständige
ministerin in einem ausdrücklich
weltlichen land im jahr des herrn 2009
10 das ist doch wahnsinn
ja und ich idiot achte religion wer bei
uns privatsache wir schalten wir live zu
birte schneider
sie leitet den frau kalex ministerium
die neu gegründete abteilung für
christliche forschung aus schneider
warum sind sie schwarz weiß bitte ach so
ja das weltbild unserer ministerin ist
aus dem jahr 1952 und da gab es noch
keine farbe ich sage immer wenn gott
farben gewollt hätte hätte er die bibel
bunt gemalt
das macht sie habe ich ihre ministerin
eben richtig verstanden fortschritt und
forschung müssen sich der religion
beugen bei ihm klingt das als wäre das
was schlechtes wir bekommen da auch ganz
ganz viele positive reaktionen hier
postkarte liebe anja herzlichen
glückwunsch zur einführung des
gottesstaates bussi die mullahs aus
teheran ist ja mit herr welke man darf
ja trotzdem weiter forschen nur eben
christ ich hier zum beispiel ein
lieblingsprojekt von unserer anja wir
messen die hirnströme von einem 16
jährigen der bei einem schwulen paar
lebt wir wollen also mal ganz
unvoreingenommen wissen wie viel dümmer
wird so ein kind wenn es von [ __ ]
aufgezogen das ist unfair
ja klar da gibt es ja auch motorische
fähigkeiten also kann so ein armer junge
der bei hinter ladern aufwächst
überhaupt noch vernünftig einen ball
fangen testen mir mal bitte gerade kann
er nicht weil gefühl wie ein mädchen
ich hatte es vermutet
aber jetzt haben wir den
wissenschaftlichen beweis eher werke
er will die christliche forschung liegt
voll im trend gesundheitsminister sparen
hat gerade von der groko fans millionen
für ein forschungsprojekt bekommen das
nachweisen wird wie schlimm die
psychischen folgen von abtreibungen für
frauen sind sie aber auch dazu gibt es
doch längst internationale studien
aber wir wollen eine wo drinsteht wie
sehr die hinterher leiden die schlamm
die frauen
herr welke sämtliche groko sätze werden
jetzt noch mal christlich geprüft auch
dieses seltsame gute kita gesetz von der
spd also ich hab da auch sicher noch mal
die ganze bibel durchgelesen ich finde
da keine einzige stelle wo maria
vormittags den kleinen jesus bei fremden
leuten abgibt
sorry steht hier nicht alles klar
mein mann sagt ich darf nicht mehr
arbeiten ich komme sofort schatz es
nicht fertig